usually when you do this with television
cameras they all say all together
breakfast but we try and set up his file
okay what was your first computer I
liked a breakfast question better
I had a Commodore 64 of course my first
computer was an IBM mainframe at the
Glasgow school's computer center in
1972-73
it was a BBC computer and uh now she
tell a lie it wasn't it was a dragon 32
the first computer i'm Strad so IBM
pc-compatible oh it was a 486 my first
computer was a zx81 with one kilobyte of
memory you know I actually don't know
what the first computer was that the
first computer that I think I saw was an
IBM 650 which is kind of a long time ago
my first computer was an Amiga Commodore
it was a Nikon electron 16 K of RAM I
guess technically a spectrum something
where the first computer sir Philips mi6
personally it was probably a very boring
Compaq PC in about 2003 but the first
ones I really got good with were
probably an acorn archimedes in the
early 90s my first computer I ever used
was called an elliot 903 it was a
Spectrum 48k
I think we had a BBC micro at school
it's up there so there that's the first
computer I built yes it was the Linux
machine in Trinity College in Dublin
calliphoridae first computer was the
sinclair zx81 that was actually mine but
the one that I had a lot of love for is
the nasco which is the first one I ever
touched yeah with a Windows 3.1 on it my
first computer was an Amstrad 286 first
computer I ever used was a mainframe
believe it or not my first interaction
with the computer was the one at the
local library
everybody had 30 minutes of free use and
free into dial-up internet access the
first computer I ever used was a
Commodore pet when I was about three and
a half years old it was a sort of
toss-up between a very early PC running
just ms-dos
what's not Windows but I think almost is
exactly the same time I got a pc-based
UNIX system my first PC was a vigilant
386 SX a lot more interesting first
computer actually to the firm I just
said PC just out of habit
someone will say the Commodore 64 is a
piece missing
tell me about your Commodore 64 them it
was primarily spying games we had the
Commodore 64 data set which is a
fascinating piece of tape record kit it
also sprays things in order to read
stuff on tape I used it for playing
games and then actually because my dad
run a small company at a time he thought
this is really useful then he nicked it
from me to use it as this eventually
computer in his company so I didn't have
it for you really annoying Amiga 500 oh
yeah that's it that was a good one good
good games or not and then he was the
286 yes I am old enough to a originally
programmed on punch cards it was
considered a bit barak even in those
days but that's how we did it we learned
to program on Farfan using punch cards
after that I went to university in
Cambridge and we programmed on pdp-8 so
I was doing the maths degree numerical
analysis is one of our courses I was
having my parents clear out their house
a couple of months ago because they were
moving and found the dragon 32 with the
couple of games one of which was manic
miner which think was as if the ZX
spectrum but it's on a cassette a little
trickier chuck yeager yes it was the
town hall the town hall computer and I
was at school and we wrote on bits of
paper and sent them away and a week
later you know yeah we ran it it didn't
work you know a couple of words make
sure you speaking the banana was a very
tasty for breakfast today
that was what we should talk about isn't
it what to eat for breakfast no what was
your first computer I tell you what I've
been to a dinner the other day with our
external examiner's and they were
talking about what was the first
computer they programmed on but but
they're obviously 6070 years old yeah I
had no idea what they were talking about
the gg4 worden flop or some fixes just I
wish they talked about a breakfast
instead of what you have a breakfast to
say tell me about first computer I use
dirty Limerick my first computer was a
zx81 with one kilobyte of memory which
could just about plague-like seon's
until you got the memory upgrade which
closed you 16 kilobytes and then you
could play pac-man and that was about
the state of it but that's what I used
to learn how to do basic programming and
then I got aesthetic spectrum which I
taught myself to programming assembler
because basics to slow the keyboards
were sort of fetishists dream rubber
which got really sweaty under your
fingertips and generally failed after
about six months so there was entire
separate industry involved in making
knockoff keyboard replacements for
zelich spectrums which you had to
install yourself at home and just hope
you didn't fry the internals with the
static electricity because at the time
no one knew that you were supposed to
earth yourself so my first computer was
an Amiga Commodore it had 16 megabytes
of RAM and it took about five minutes to
load a basic word processor yeah sure it
was shredded wheat with milk sorry I you
know I actually don't know what the
first computer was it the first computer
that I think I saw was an IBM 650 which
is kind of a long time ago and the first
one that I probably did anything with
might have been an IBM 1620 which was a
little on and by the standards at the
time and an IBM 7090 4 which was the big
computer at the University of Toronto
that actually was well I was an
undergraduate so that would be 63 64
mostly punch cards all I think it's
possible that the 1620 used paper tape I
don't remember now at this point so
definitely the good old days crikey I
guess technically a spectrum something
other but I really got going with a
Commodore 64 and played plenty of games
had polled on Ataris as well it kind of
had that version of basic which wasn't
quite the same as BBC basic but it was
almost BBC basic and I had a BBC basic
programming manual this was back in 1986
when I was six years old and I got
really hooked at that age my dad wrote a
very simple program for me to do maths
and then I changed it a lot and it had
one of those nice cartridges that you
could slot in yeah that was brilliant
I loved programming basic on that I
think it was nine years old basically
really for life though it did not know
although I didn't ever begin a big gap
in which I did not program at all my
first computer I ever used was called an
Elliott 903 and indeed I have one in a
spare room at my house I spent a bit of
time in my summer vacations as a student
working for the company that made them
and we use in building flight control
systems for the Nimrod and what is now
called the tornado so I've memorized the
instruction set of that machine
programmer in my sleep still had these
enormous floppy disks which are probably
actually much smaller right because I
was much smaller so a very special what
was your favorite game on it or program
yeah manic miner I did loads of basic I
don't know how big they were they were
definitely bigger than the regular ones
but I remember them being like huge I
walk around with them like this because
I went back and the entire school is
smaller now than it was so rubber keys
that's all I remember
and how it was very hard to type first
computer first computer was when I was
very young talking late 80s which dates
me which is unstrap the IBM pc compatibl
currently the exact numbers numbers 1512
that went ahead like that might be model
number something like that the first
computer that a lot of people around
here the guys who work here at arm
remember from having had in their
bedrooms and the ones that they learned
to program on is the first one that I
actually worked on producing actually
part of so that was the BBC
microcomputer I came a little bit too
late - for Commodore 64's and all that
like they were still out there but I was
always always always on PCs all the way
through and it had a hardest it was
about 20 megabytes of hard disk which
was plenty
you know it played games sort of it had
four whole colors it's great I worked
for a competent Oulton C in Cambridge
and these crazy nutters over the other
side of town had this idea that they
were going to build computers and they
were going to put them in every home and
every school and things like that and it
was obviously complete insanity but we
thought we'd help him out and they paid
our bills so why not
was that get formal did you know no said
tighly home designed including anodizing
the aluminium in the kitchen sink and
things like that Susan I built that when
I was at I think a PhD student at
Cambridge and I joined the Cambridge
University process a group and that was
a Society for students who built
computers for fun the real men built
everything out of TTL and the wimps like
me use these newfangled microprocessor
things so that's a microprocessor based
computer and yeah I think we know where
that went does it yeah it's sort of in
the long run have a career transforming
impact funny yeah defining as a better
word yes yes that's right cost a
relative fortune unbelievably slow but
it was all mine not very fast not very
powerful not much memory and but it did
the job and then when I went to Oxford
to do my PhD
we had some faster once again they were
Linux were they were UNIX actually Sun
workstations and gradually over time
then we've migrated up to larger and
larger systems in the loft we have one
of those old ones it's an a4 screen
that's green only but I never did find
out one that was so you had a four oh
six would you use it for Peter Krogh a
ball game game mainly had an Amiga as
well for dynamite ducks and worms the
original the NASS gone was a kick
computer British machine it was
basically a kit form machine that you
could buy the balls for and then put
together yourself no two Ness coms look
the same they're all different as na T
based system but it's just one that my
uncle had
I just went around is one evening with
my dad and used this computer and he
built it in a way was in a case like
kegs very similar to that in a way but
it had metal cross stretch kind of Linda
so you can see in it and the cards had
LEDs on and the only things blinked as
it was doing stuff and so yeah yeah big
time
big time and I was completely blown away
by it I just remember is I mean I was
only about I've no sight ish the drive
home that night when you're a kid and
you're in that kind of half between
asleep and awake just dreaming about
that was Shane and all the things I
could potentially do with it and that
just that that's the most vivid dream
I've ever remembered just the first time
I saw and touched a computer some
amazing Zachary it was mostly games
tried a little bit of programming didn't
really take to it to start with and my
parents have still got it my brother got
it out the first challenge was finding
something you could plug it into for a
screen because all the TVs have got at
the right analog input anymore so we
ended up with a video recorder with the
right analog input my brother had to go
and make a cable so that he could
connect it then from the into the video
recorder via recorder connects the TV so
we could play out of it and then my two
kids got to see some games Monte on the
run in particular being loaded and then
playing them the thing that confused
them the most was the idea that you put
the tape in and waited for like ten
minutes before you could play that this
was a weird experience for me because
you only got thirty minutes and you had
a lot of stuff you wanted to do on the
Internet
you would pre plan all of the things you
wanted to do and it was basically trying
to like batch process so trying to
optimize how you would use your
connection working with other people so
that you could like break up the things
if you were trying to do some homework
or something one person would use one
website one person would use another to
help with the caching and then you kind
of split up and it was all the game was
all about optimizing to get that 30
minutes of weekly confuse Amstrad 1512
that sounds right because my mother's
work desktop and I remember just going
to play games I couldn't even speak
English at the time and I was using
Windows in English and
that's how it started and just thinking
like 20 Meg's of lovers have one two
three Meg's around something like they
was was a 15 12 a yeah um the some of
them came with two floppy disks her
actual five a quarter-inch floppy disc
holders this one had one of those name
and crying out loud I was young if I
painted the mouse it was a miracle it
was Mike reporter Mike report UNIX and
of course it was on the old intel 80286
chips which could just about run it but
I don't know if you recall the
architecture of those things was abysmal
because if you wrote a program
no individual array or structuring it
could be bigger than 64 K it still had
16-bit limitations in here in tennis
even though it was nominally a 32-bit
chip that was all removed with the 80386
and 80486 but boy did I live with him
under UNIX but now mine those were the
days yeah but it came to the mouse in
this this being me about age one three
four something like that I I thought my
foreground so I painted the male's brown
and amazingly it kept working and what
is was it running then can you remember
I was running that was running really
early DOS must wind us three something
like that I'm not sure um it was
certainly pre Windows pre anything like
that I think we though we tried to get
something called gen running on it and I
thought that was a computer after which
it was never never the right thing but
yeah it was command-line it what it
wasn't too hard to understand I think I
might have a first bit of programming
was batch files on that